Prices for everyday goods are soaring worldwide.
That's particularly true in parts of Asia and North Africa,...
...where people spend a bigger proportion of their incomes on food.
In the Kazakh hub of Almaty, some shoppers say it's becoming a battle.
Consumers in Almaty cite flour and sugar...
...as among the staples being hoarded.
Similar stories are told in North African countries...
...like Tunisia, Algeria and Libya.
Price rises in such developing countries...
...are running well above even western Europe's elevated levels.
In Egypt, inflation hit 13.6% in July,...
...while in Turkey it was 80% in August.
Shoppers in the region are spending less on nonessentials...
...like clothing and electronics as a result.
In Kazakhstan, people are adapting.
The world's big food firms have taken note.
Nestle says it's noticed hoarding of soups and coffee.
It's now adapting product ranges in Asia and North Africa in response.
On the agenda are increased pack sizes and cheaper ingredients.
In Almaty though, that won't be a solution for everyone.
Some shoppers say money is now too tight to buy in bulk.